Schön.
Schön, guten Morgen.
Mein Name ist, ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt auf dieser Station und würde gerne mit
Ihnen das Patientengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstanden?
Ja, guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen.
Kurz zum Ablauch, ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Dann können mich zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, melden Sie sich bitte dabei mir.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Thomas Bauch.
Thomas mit Haar.
Bauch, Sie haben gesagt.
Bauch.
Oh.
B-A-U-C-H.
Ihr Bauch, genau.
Ihr Bauch.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geworden, Herr Bauch?
Ich bin geboren am 25.1.82, mit 41 Jahren alt.
Danke.
Wie groß und wie viel wie ich kieken Sie schon seit, Herr Bauch?
Ich bin ungefähr 1.71 groß und wiege circa 85 Kilo.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Herr Bauch.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also ich habe seit ungefähr jetzt schon 2 Tagen zunehmende Schmerzen im Bauch.
Könnte Sie mir sagen, wo die Schmerzen am stärksten sind,
in der rechte Seite, linker Seite Oberbauch, Unterbauch?
Die sind insbesondere heute, sind wir im rechten Unterbauch.
Haben die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich bewohnen?
Die haben ja plötzlich bekommen.
Plötzlich bekommen?
Also die plötzlich waren die da und dann habe ich Schmerzmedikamente genommen
und waren sie auch wieder weg und jetzt sind sie wieder da.
Darf ich fragen, welche Medikamente haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe die Profäne eingenommen.
Profäne.
Einmal, oder?
Ja, jetzt zwei, drei Mal genommen.
Ich habe die Plastik ja schon seit 2-3 Tagen.
Sind die Schmerzen auch in der rechte Unterbauch auch getreten
oder um der Nabel oder strahlende Schmerzen in einer anderen Körperregion?
Ja, die sind tatsächlich im Oberbauch angefangen und sind so ein bisschen gewandert.
Aber auch Strahlungen haben Sie nicht für die Schmerzen?
Wie meinen Sie aus Strahlungen?
Ich meine, diese Schmerzen fangen mit einer anderen Körperregion
und in der Laufe der Zeit, aber das ist ja gewandert.
Sie haben gesagt, im Oberbauch die Schmerzen angefangen
und im Laufe der Zeit in der Unterbauch gehe.
Könnten Sie mir diese Schmerzen etwas genauer beschreiben?
Sie die Schmerzen, ja, dumpf, drückend, stehend, ziehend, willend, vor mich.
Also die sind eher so dumpf, aber auch stechend manchmal?
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskalle anstufen
von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leid, 10 sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich würde schon sagen, so 6, ungefähr 6, 7.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindern oder verstiegeln?
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, Ibuprofenchid, gibt es eine Linie?
Ja, also es wird mehr, wenn ich tatsächlich so ein bisschen gehe
oder Treppensteiger oder so.
Hatten Sie schon einmal solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, noch nie.
Nein, das ist das. Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit, mussten Sie sich übergeben, Herr Wauch?
Übelkeit habe ich, aber ich habe es nicht mehr geben.
Ja, haben Sie jährliche Farbveränderung in der Augen
oder auf die Haut aber merkt? Nein.
Haben Sie Buschmerzen, Dispene, Atemnot? Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlverhalten, ist alles in Ordnung mit dem Stuhlgang
und beim Masselassen verbar?
Ich habe tatsächlich seit ungefähr seit 2 Tagen etwas brennen
und ein bisschen Durchfall, aber nichts Wildes eigentlich.
Brennen beim Masselassen, Sie haben gesagt, oder beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, sowohl beim Masselassen ein bisschen brennen,
als auch etwas flüssigeren Stuhl.
Mäßig.
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches in jedem Stuhlbemerk?
Ich meine, ist mehr Schleimisch oder Blutbemerk in einem Stuhl?
Blut habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nur wässig.
Ja.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für die Schmerzen?
Ja, eine bestimmte Auslösung für die Schmerzen,
zum Beispiel Nahrungsabhängig, Bewegung,
oder haben Sie etwas Unfall?
Wenn ich Treppen steige, sind die ein bisschen mehr,
habe ich eben gesagt.
Aber ansonsten nichts mit der Nahrung.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, beim Waslassen, Sie haben eine brennende Schmerzen.
Haben Sie in Ihrem Urin Blut oder Papterendrumpemerk?
Nein.
Haben Sie viel beigemessen oder leider unter Stütthorst herbau?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube,
ich habe ein bisschen elbe Temperaturen, aber ich habe nicht gemessen.
Nein, ich verstehe.
Schlafen Sie gut? Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Angewicht verloren?
Nein, auch nicht.
Sie haben keine Probleme beim Schlafen, das bedeutet,
leiden Sie nicht unter Nachtschweiß?
Nein, eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Okay, danke schön.
Ja, Herr Bau, ich würde gerne nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen.
Leiden Sie an Vorerkrankungen von denen ich wissen sollte?
Mir nicht bewusst.
Das freut mich.
Leiden Sie sich oder gelegen dich eine bestimmte Medikamente,
außer diese Epopropfen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Das freut mich auch.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Herr Bau?
Ich habe die Mandeln raus, meine Mandeln wurden.
Ja, wann war das?
Da war ich zehn Jahre alt, ungefähr, das ist schon ein bisschen länger her.
Ja, über 30 Jahre her.
Sie Kind war, ich verstehe.
Sind bei Ihnen alle geblieben, bekannt, Herr Bau?
Hausstorpe, alle hier habe ich.
Hausstorpe, wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Jukreiz und Niesen.
Niesen, ja.
Würde ich gerne nach Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit fragen,
Herr Bau, darf man Sie?
Nein.
Kann man Sie nie geraucht, oder?
Ab und zu, also bei Gelegenheit.
Aber ich bin jetzt nicht jemand, der Zigaretten kauft.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke Gelegenheit durch Alkohol.
Ja, und was meine Sie, geht Ihnen?
Feier, Feier, Geburtstag,
oder bei Weihnachten, oder?
Darf ich sagen, was trinken Sie?
Was es an gibt?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich glaube,
ob es Bier gibt, ob es Wein gibt,
und es kommt darauf an.
Danke, danke.
Das ist eine Routinefrage,
bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Jetzt aktuell?
Ja.
Ob ich droge, nein?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich interessiere mich für die vorherige auch.
Haben Sie, hatten Sie einen Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Oder so seit, haben Sie Kontakt?
Also ich habe noch nie Drogen, oder?
Ja, ich habe noch nie.
Haben Sie interessieren sich für Drogen?
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe jetzt...
Haben Sie interessieren sich für Drogen?
Ich?
Ja, dass Sie interessieren sich für Drogen.
Nein, habe ich nicht erlebt.
Aber ich habe in Deutschland gehört,
dass es ein sehr üblich ist.
Mit Drogen?
Ja, Drogen.
Ja, in der Türkei ist es nicht so häufig zu sehen,
aber hier in Deutschland in der Bau,
Hauptbahnhof oder etwas...
Ja?
Ich habe vielmals gesehen.
Okay.
Herr Bauch, lebt Ihre Eltern noch?
Beide leben noch, ja.
Das freut mich.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, die haben beide einen Blutwuchdruck
und beide leiden an Diabetes.
Also, wenn Sie einen Zucker in den Kranken gucken.
Ja.
Was machen Sie wirklich in der Bau?
Ich bin Informatiker.
Informatiker, ja.
Wo arbeiten Sie?
Sie können mir sagen.
Das ist eine Firma in Köln.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Geht so.
Es kann viel von zu Hause aus arbeiten.
Aber es ist in Ordnung.
Ich habe gerne eine.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sie können sich tun, oder?
Es ist okay.
Ja, das freut mich.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstand, Herr Bauch?
Ich bin ledig.
Ledig? Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Okay, das freut mich.
Vielen Dank für alle Informationen, Herr Bauch.
Jetzt würde ich gerne ein...
Was glauben Sie, dass ich das habe?
Ja, wenn...
In erster Linie werde ich jetzt
eine kleine Zusammenfassung machen.
Wenn ich etwas falsch sagte,
oder wenn Sie etwas korrigieren möchte,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Sie haben seit drei Tagen Bauchschmerzen.
Es fang mit dem Nabelbereich.
Aber im Laufe der Zeit,
diese Schmerzen waren in den Rechtern unter Bauch.
Sie leiden...
Das ist ein Oberbauchbereich, das angefangen ist.
Ja, das ist ein Oberbauchbereich.
Aber diese Schmerzen sind dunkel,
dunkel und sterb.
Und eine Schmerzskalarbeit ist 7 Lege.
Sie leiden unter Übelkeit,
aber mussten Sie sich nicht übergeben.
Sie haben keine phabri-
ländische Papieränderung.
Sie haben auch Durchfahrt,
wässig und Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Sie sind ein bisschen brennend.
Sie haben auch Durchfahrt, wässig und Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Sie möchten etwas hinzufügen?
Oder möchten Sie mich korrigieren?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich bin nur neugierig, was ich habe.
Ja, ich habe eine Verdacht gesteckt.
Aber ich brauche die andere zweite Witter
für meine Untersuchungen.
Das bedeutet, ich würde gerne Sie
körperisch untersuchen,
dann Ihnen Blut abnehmen
und eine Sonografie durchführen
für Ihre Bauchschmerzen.
Aber mein Verdacht...
Eine was?
Ultraschall, Bauchultraschall, ich meine,
das ist eine Untersuchungsmethode,
Bildgebirgene.
Und mit Hilfe dieser Ultraschall
können wir inneren Organe genauer
sehen und bewutzeilen,
wie Nieren, Milz oder Bauch.
Eine Bauchspiegel?
Es ist nicht so.
Es ist nicht stehende Untersuchungen.
Wir haben eine Schall,
Kopfschall,
und wir beruhigen Ihre Bauch
mit diesem Schall, mit der Kontaktgähn.
Es ist nicht wie ein Spiegelung.
Also keine Lakose oder so was?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das dauert ungefähr zehn Minuten.
Schmerzlos, strahlendose Therapie.
Machen Sie das in der Ambulanz?
Ja, können wir diese machen hier in der Ambulanz.
Wir haben Geräte für das.
Und wenn alle
befunden vorliegen,
komme ich zu Ihnen und
wir sprechen über Ihren Fall.
Ihren Risikation.
Haben Sie schon alle Verdacht,
dass Sie sich in der Ambulanz
verhindern?
Ja, ich habe fast vergessen.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf
diese
Handweginfekt
oder
Blinddarm Entzündung.
Aber Sie haben
keinen Fieber gemessen.
Das bedeutet,
sollte ich jetzt Ihre Vitalparameter.
Bei Blinddarm Entzündung,
das heißt, der muss operiert werden?
Ja, jeder Blinddarm Entzündung
muss nicht operiert werden.
Bei der Ultraschall
können wir diese
Duschmessung der Blinddarm messen.
Wenn es mehr als
1 cm,
leider sollten Sie operiert werden.
Aber weniger
7 oder 6 cm.
Das bedeutet, wir können mit Antibiotherapika
oder mit Flüssigkeitstherapie
hier behandeln.
Ich habe mal gehört,
der
Vater von meinem
Bekannten
ist mal an einem blinddarm Durchbruch gestorben.
Das ist gefährlich, oder?
Ja, leider würde ich sagen,
das ist dann gefährlich.
Aber Sie haben
Platz für Blinddarm.
Sie haben per Vorrat.
Ich konnte nicht,
Sie genauer
verstehen.
Der hat einen blinddarm Durchbruch gehabt.
Dann hat der einen Schein
eine Vergiftung gehabt
und ist dann gestorben.
Das ist ja dann auch gefährlich, oder?
Ja, das ist sehr gefährlich.
Aber wir werden
jetzt Labor untersuchen,
wenn es um eine Entzündung gibt.
Und auch
eine Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Und das Rauschen
und Bauchultraschall?
Damit wir sehr genau sehen.
Da muss man nicht
rüber gehen,
das braucht man nicht.
Es ist nicht erforderlich, aber
wenn wir bei der Bauchultraschall
keine wesentliche Befunde bekommen,
können wir
diese Computertomographie durchführen.
Also ich bitte Sie,
wirklich alles durchzuchecken bei mir.
Ja, ja, ja.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorge, Sie sind bei mir.
Also ich möchte hier,
ich kann auch hier bleiben, im Kanton ausbleiben.
Ich habe kein Problem damit.
Das ist bei mir einmal.
Vielen Dank für Ihr Verständnis.
Aufmerksamkeit,
ich mache keine Sorge, Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen.
Jetzt werde ich
Ihrem Fall mit meinem Chef ansprechen.
Ist der auch hier?
Ja, ja.
Kann ich Ihnen auch gleich sprechen?
Ich würde auch.
Ja.
Ich kann nicht sagen,
dass Sie nicht aufmerksam sind.
Natürlich.
Natürlich können Sie sprechen, aber
wir sind hier
als Teamarbeiten.
Und wenn ich Ihre
Fall zu meinem Chefarzt erzählen,
können Sie
auch mit ihm sprechen.
Okay.
Ich dachte, nur Privatpatienten können mit dem Chef
Arzt sprechen.
Deswegen.
Wir sind hier Arzt und unsere Pflicht,
um Patienten zu kümmen.
Okay.
Ich fühle mich gut aufgehoben hier.
Dankeschön.
Das freut mich.
Soll ich Sie hier warten?
Ja, Sie warten bitte.
Sie hier.
Ich komme in 5 Minuten,
um Sie zu untersuchen.
Dann, ja, okay.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen
eine andere Frage?
Ich erweite.
Ja, ich will.
Sind Sie
vollständig gegen Corona?
Ich bin vollständig gegen Corona.
Ja.
Und noch eine.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Okay.
Ist das möglich,
dass Sie in der Lesterzeit
verdorben etwas gegessen?
Kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern.
Ich erhebe mich eigentlich immer
gleich
und versuche mich gesund zu ändern.
Ich fahre mich draußen
im Restaurant.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe auch nicht im Ausland.
Ich habe auch eine Frage über
gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Oder haben Sie bemerkt,
dass Sie mehrmals auf die Toilette gehen?
Nein.
Nein, ich.
Ich fahre auch nicht im Ausland.
Und
wir müssen eben
von Fern dosieren.
Wie oft habe ich das eingenommen?
Wie viele Milligramm
und wie oft?
Ich habe die
frei verkäuft, die ich in der Apotheke geholt habe.
Das sind glaube ich 400 Milligramm.
Ich habe 2-3 Stück eingenommen.
Vielleicht
als 2 oder 3 erinnere ich mich nicht ganz genau.
Wenn Sie
im Fern eingenommen,
dann haben Sie
die
Bemerkungen, die Sie eingenommen haben,
das sind besser geworden.
Komplett weg?
Nicht komplett.
Aber besser.
Die
sind immer
dünn,
sehr fähig.
Die sind immer
dünn,
sehr fähig.
Nein, nein.
Sie sind immer
da, dumpf
und manchmal stechend.
Wenn ich mich bewege,
wenn ich treppen steige,
dann tut es weh.
Wenn ich belaste so ein bisschen.
Jetzt momentan,
wo die Schmelzen am Stechsten sind?
Die sind momentan
im rechten Unterbau am stärksten.
Danke schön.
Wenn ich so drauf drücke,
dann tut das richtig weh.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Gut.
Hat sich nicht verändert.
Können wir anfangen als Schiprae?
Ja.
Bitte schön.
Guten Morgen, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe gerade einen neuen Patientin gesehen
und würde gerne
Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja.
Herr Trommersbau,
Sie ist 41 Jahre alt
und ist ein...
41 Jahre alt
und ist am
25.
1982 gebohnt.
Er ist 1,71 Meter groß
und 85 kg schwer.
Herr Baustellte sich heute bei uns
wegen vor zwei Tagen
plus sich aufgetretene,
progredierende,
dumpferstechende
Oberbauschmerzen
vor.
Er gab an, dass die Schmerzen
im Oberbau aufgetreten
seien, aber im Laufe der Zeit
waren die Schmerzen
in den rechtern unteren
Bauch gewandert.
Und
die Schmerzen würden auf
einer Schmerzskala
bei sieben liegen ohne Ausstrahlung.
Er
klagte
Klage über
Übelkeit ohne Emesis
und auch
die Zufriedenheit
und einmalige Diarrheur.
Er ist wässrig
ohne erkennbares Blut.
Und
er sagte,
dass die Schmerzen bei der Bewegung
besonders beim Treppensteigen
immer schlimmer geworden seien.
Hermaturgie
Icterus
und
Melena wurden von den Patienten
verneint.
Er war
nicht gemessen
und hatte keine Probleme
mit B-Sympathie.
Er ist unauffällig.
Und
bei den Patienten
seien keine Vorerkrankungen,
bis her bekannt.
Er
nehmt keine Dauermedikation.
Bei den Patienten
wurden
mit 10. Lebensjahr
ein Ponsylektomö durchgeführt.
Er sei allergisch
auf Haus, Stau
und RB, Provitus und Renitis
dagegen.
Er sei
nicht rauchig, er trinke
ab und zu ein Fleisch Bier,
Drogenkonsum von den Patienten
verneint.
In der Familie
in der Anamnese ergab sich Folgendes.
Beide
Familienmitglied leiden
mit der Hypertonie
und Diabetes mellitus.
Er
war Informatiker
bei einer Firma in Köln.
Er sei ledig
und
hat keine Kinder.
An amnestische Angaben
deuten am 1. auf
eine Urolithiasis
hin.
Als differential Diagnotisch
kommt
akute Apandesitis in den Tracht.
Meine
Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen
werde ich Folgende Untersuchungen durchführen.
Er ist mal körperliche Untersuchungen.
Ich
meine Klopfschmerzen
in der rechten und linke Flanke
und los lasse Schmerzen bei der Rechtern
unter Bau.
Obwärtsspannung werde ich durchführen.
Als
Laborparameter werde ich Blutbild,
Entzündungsparameter, Leber-
und
Urinstatus und Urinkultur
durchführen.
Urinkultur
ist nicht so erforderlich,
aber bei der Antibiotika
können wir diese
auch auf diese Akten.
Dann werde ich
Sonografieabdomen durchführen, um
meine Differenzialdiagnose
auszuschließen.
Zum Beispiel, Haumark Infekt,
Pyronephritis und Akute Apandesitis
werden wir
in der Rechtern
durchführen.
Es gibt eine geringe Möglichkeit
um diese Steine
zu sehen.
Gegebenenfalls
werde ich
eine Computer-Tomographie
durchführen.
Ja,
ja,
das ist
alles.
Was meinen Sie, Herr Oberatz?
Was glauben Sie denn eher?
Er hat
beschrieben, dass er
umfischwärzend hat,
mit ab und zu stechendem Charakter,
wie er auch provozieren kann,
wenn er treppen läuft.
Ja, bei der die Bürger sind.
Ist er eher so für Urulutiasis
oder passt das eher doch
zu einer Apandesitis?
Schließt
ein Haarenwegsinfekt
und geht es aus?
Oder kann das beides auftreten?
Könnte es beides auftreten,
aber im Erzterlinie
habe ich diese
gewusst,
dass bei der Bewegung
Stehändeschmerzen
und die Suguet
ich denke an
die Urulutiasis in Erzterlinien
und auch
Urulutiasis haben sie eher
auch beschwerdenen Ruhe,
die müssen wiederkommen.
Wenn Stehänden
Haarenleiter
verkrampft,
dann tut das weh.
Das ist eine kollegartige Schmerz.
Die Patienten
können nicht auf der
auf dem gleichen Platz sitzen bleiben.
Die müssen sich immer bewegen.
Haben Sie schon mal gesehen,
jemanden mit einer kollegartigen Schmerz?
Ja, ja, viele, viele Mal.
Wie ein Fisch, wie ich gesagt habe
mit meinen Kollegen, wie ein Fisch
immer bewegt.
Die Bewegung muss sich die ganze Zeit,
die können nicht da bleiben, hier bleiben.
Die müssen immer bewegen.
Ich habe gedacht,
dass die Steine ein bisschen groß
und verengt
diese Haarenleiter
und vielleicht bei der Bewegung
diese Steine ein bisschen bewegen
und wenn die Patienten, aber sie haben völlig Recht.
Aus diesem Grund
möchte ich akute Apandesitis sein,
und bei der Bewegung diese
Nein, Sie können,
welche Übungen können Sie dem Patienten
machen lassen,
wo Sie erkennen können,
ob es tatsächlich eine
Apandesitis ist oder nicht.
Es gibt eine bestimmte
Übung.
Ja, Übung,
ich die auf die Zähne
stehen
und dann
plötzlich auf die Färze
oder Sie sagen den Patienten springen Sie mal hoch.
Ja, ja, auch.
Springen Sie mal 2-mal hoch.
Und wenn die Schmerzen haben,
oft ein Zeichen, eine Apandesitis,
sogenannte Erschütterungsschmerz.
Wenn Sie jetzt den Verdacht,
Ihr beschreibt auch manchmal,
wenn Sie jetzt zum Beispiel
Treppen steigeln,
und da müssten Sie als Stufen steigen.
Also Sie müssten immer so
Suchen steigen,
dann kann das auch mal so ein
Muskuluspsoas Schmerz sein.
Muskuluspsoas kann auch mal
Schmerzen.
Das kann auch sein, wenn der
Blinder ein bisschen falsch
belegen ist.
Wenn Sie jetzt den Verdacht haben
auf einer
Blindermensündung, apandesitis,
welche Untersuchung
machten Sie bei den Patienten?
Körperlöschen untersuchbar.
Körperlöschen untersuchbar
Auf der Finettmanlaster gibt es
Schmerz.
Losz das Schmerz ist richtig, genau.
Der Pfand.
Haben Sie schon mal etwas von
McBurney gehört?
Ja, das ist ein Punkt.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz
genauer Punkt der apandesitis.
Und ich glaube
von der Narbe und aus
ich her
mit einem Finger zu messen
und die
zwei und direkt gerückt
und dann
ja, ich kann
nicht unter dem Bau, das
bedeutet, dass es McBurney ist.
Also, das gibt es auch mit dem McBurney
Punkt.
Zwischen Spinaeliaca anterior
und Bauchnarbe.
Und dann gibt es noch
den Lance Punkt.
Das ist der Punkt
zwischen beiden
Spinaeliaca anterior
rechts und links
und den mittleren Drittel.
Also, ein Drittel wieder.
Mittleren Drittel, ja.
Okay.
Es gibt verschiedene Zeichen, die können ich nochmal durchlesen.
Einmal, ich möchte jetzt nicht alle aufführen.
Ja.
Aber die sollten Sie schon
im Blickwinkel haben, im Auge haben.
Dankeschön.
McBurney
Lance Punkt, McBurney Punkt, los las ich
merzen. Und ist das auch möglich
abwährend
Abwehrspannung.
Definitiv.
Können Sie die Psoas zeichnen?
Psoas, muss ich das Psoas zeichnen?
Nein, leider.
Können Sie das Menüver Lasek?
Lasek, ja.
Ich habe diese Beinaufhebung
eine belitzende Schmerzen
in der Hucke.
Genau, wenn Sie zum Beispiel
das Bein anheben
und
das Sie dann
wenn Sie das quasi
gegen den Widerstand
sowas wie Lasek ungefähr,
aber Sie müssten das Knie zum Beispiel
hochziehen, ja.
Drücken dagegen gegen Widerstand.
Dann ist das so ein Psoas-Schmerz.
Psoas, okay.
Es ist ungefähr wie Lasek,
aber gegen Widerstand.
Dankeschön.
Da gibt es verschiedene Zeichen
und verschiedene Untersuchungsmöglichkeiten
in dem
können Sie nochmal nachlesen
im Untersuch einer Mesebuch
oder körperlich Untersuchung.
Ja, ich habe jetzt in meinem Kopf
diese alle belegen.
Ja, danke.
Gut.
Wenn es eine Frau wäre,
woran würden Sie noch denken?
Ja, bei der Frau
achte ich auch diese geneachologische Anamnese
und könnte es sein
Nexitis
und auch Extra-Otteregrivität
oder Schwangerschaft.
Ja, ja, ich habe schon geschaut
oder auch wieder ein bisschen.
Ja.
Sie machen jetzt einen Ultraschall,
haben Sie gesagt, in den Blutern.
Ich würde direkt mit Blutkulturen
abnehmen.
Und
was machen wir mit den Patienten dann?
Oh ja,
wie die Patienten nüchtern bleiben lassen
und sind bis zu acht Stunden.
Erst mal, wie müssen diese denken,
dann mit Antibioterapika.
Was können Sie im Ultraschall
sehen,
wenn Sie gut Ultraschall machen?
Ja, diese
ödematöse Vergrößerung
der Wunsch fortsetzt
und
diese innähere Gewebe
ein bisschen
schmutzige Nähere
die Gewebe nicht schmutzig.
Müßigkeit
Ja,
Müßigkeit in der Nähere Gewebe.
Wenn es
schon perforiert ist,
dann können Sie
Luft sehen.
Gut.
Sie können sehen,
ob der Blind dann so
kokadenförmig ist.
Das ist so wie eine Zitscheibe.
Kann man sehen.
Kokaden.
Können Sie doch mal nachlesen.
Kokaden
ARDM
und wenn Sie den Ultraschall gut darstellen können,
ob der Blind dann
verdickt ist.
Können Sie mehr als 6 mm
zum Beispiel, ob der verdickt ist.
Jetzt haben die zum Beispiel
Dokadenphänomen.
Sie können zum Beispiel aber auch
jetzt ein Patient haben,
der viel Luft hat
und den Blind
dann gar nicht sehen können.
Was machen Sie dann?
Ja,
ich werde ein
Computatomographier Abdomen mit
Kontrastmitteilung schlüpfen.
Damit ich genau sehen kann.
Aber ich muss zuerst,
ich habe erst einmal gesagt, dass
es erholt ist. Ich muss zuerst diese ausschließen.
Genau.
Okay,
und jetzt
was machen wir therapeutisch
und wie ich gesagt habe,
nüchtern bleiben lassen,
dann Flüssigkeit, Therapie
und das ist die
Durchmesser für 1 cm ist wichtig
für uns, weil
bei der
Fehlerfälle gibt es
diese
Schmerzenlindern,
Spontanlindern
oder die Ödomatoriosveränderung
spontan gelindert
werden und wie beobachten.
Schicken Sie in der Hause oder bleibt der hier?
Nein, nein, Überwachung
in der Stationenaufnahme
und
wenn es diese
mit einer Sonografie Kontrolle
diese Durchmesser wird
ein bisschen vermehrt,
können wir chirurgische Eingriff planen
und wenn es
Herzbedingungen gibt?
Ja, ich
wenn wir überzeugt,
dass es eine Akkuterpandesit ist,
die wir uns nicht mehr geben.
Das würde
Metamisol oder
Ja, genau, richtig.
Geben Sie auch ein Antibiotikum direkt oder?
Ja, wenn wir
sehen, diese nähere Gewebe
es ist ein bisschen entzündet
oder
könnte es, aber ich bin mir
nicht sicher.
Also ich schroben geben meistens
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht
einmal ein Antibiotikum
auch vor der Operation glaube ich
vorbeugelt.
Ich bin ja bei dir sicher.
Das können vielleicht chirurgisch sagen, wie wir sind.
Ich wollte das machen.
Genau so, ja.
Manchmal geben
die einen Antibiotikum vor der Operation
und dann schaut man
wie das Ganze entwickelt.
Genau.
Gut.
Ja.
Das war okay.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe Prüfung
am 21. März
zwar diese Dienstag
Sie reden
sehr gut, sehr flüssig
finde ich, aber sie machen
so ein bisschen Flüchtigkeitsfehler,
wie er und sie
verbitzen sie so ein bisschen
die
die Pronomen,
also Mann, Frau
Ja, ja, ja.
Er ist sicher.
Er bleiben
Sie reden sehr flüssig, sehr schnell
und ich finde auch sehr sicher.
Das finde ich gut.
Also sehr gut.